[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça déménage j'en ai r bol du Rob passage
et du ménage racommodage la vachirage et
nettoyage ce soir je me mets au chômage
c'est terminé je laisse tomber j'en ai
assez je suis Liv plus faire marcher
plus éplucher plus
cuisiner ce soir je vais m'éclater
rock l'esclav c'est fini si tu es pas
content ép épouse la mère de
ni qu'est-ce que je vais
faire mange un
[Musique]
hamburger qu'est-ce que je vais devenir
ce
soir téléphone à
grgoire où est-elle
partie as regardé sous le
lit dis-lui qu'elle
revienne n oh Germain tu
arrives ciao coco j'en ai r les
ronflements dans le Doo de ton métro de
ton boulot de T
B ce soir tu dors en solo c'est terminé
plus bichonné plus dorloté plus chouchou
plus calin plus faire bisous sur
l'oreiller ce soir je suis fermé à
[Musique]
clé tout se dans ton
l les CIN c'est fin si en as
envie va voir il vaêre
rou
rentre à la
maison qu'est-ce qu'il a l'air
con je t'aime à la
folie tu l'as dit
bouffille reviens dans mon
lit oh ça va
pas reviens dans mon lit ah je préfère
ça on repart à zéro 5 4 3 2 1 0
ouais
ouais B c'est d'accord je tabliier je
prends le Balis changement de décor et
c'est pas tout je prends la pilu je fais
des efforts il y a que comme ça que je
t'adore rock rock
rock rock rock
concessions la
[Musique]
réconciliation
capitulation
concession
réation